[Music]
a to f
c
probably on the lower end of the
spectrum a to f is there what comes
after f
c minus i don't even have to say
anything look at the economy i didn't
vote for him i don't think he's doing
great at all i feel like
a lot of the things he promised he
hasn't delivered on quite yet we're both
ex-military so he's not supporting the
military at all gas prices all they want
to say it doesn't um come from biden it
does a big believer in our president is
supposed to be a symbol of power
and you know giving speeches and you
know talking you know articulately and
being able to you know really get the
american people behind him and i just
don't think he's been able to do that i
think how
the administration has handled a lot of
particular issues we've had over the
past year or two have been handled very
very poorly
i like him i give him a b-plus i didn't
vote for him well i don't agree with
most of the stuff he does
seems like a nice guy he seems like he's
getting things done i liked him an early
pandemic we want to follow all the
mandates you know do it do what the
government asks us to say but at the end
of the day you know we want to go out
and still live
i think you should just own it
i don't wear a mask either most of the
time so only unless i have to so you
have requirements for indoor and you
know outdoor mass usage and whatnot you
know just abide by our own rules maybe
he did that's great it seems
disingenuous i don't care if he wasn't
wearing his mask but i don't want him to
tell you to wear her mask for me to wear
a mouse
i have no issue with you know taking
your mask down to take a picture but um
it shouldn't be something that you have
to defend either i am of the opinion
that if you're if we're vaccinated uh i
have to show proof of vaccination
everybody's negative tests are
vaccinated i think mass work great if
you wear them by yourself while you're
in a vehicle but i think when you're
hanging out i think you ought to be able
to take it off and hang out with all
your friends